I'm recording this on may the 4th so may
the force be with you or if this gets
uploaded on the fifth revenge' that said
probably a lot more fun so this is my
spoiler talk for guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 so you've been warned I have a
spoiler free review you can go ahead and
check that out if you don't want any
spoilers consider that the morning
because I'm going to talk about some
spoilers now I'm not even going to go
step by step and talk about the whole
movie just there are a couple of things
I wanted to talk about in my review I
just couldn't because I only know that's
a spoiler
Plumber is one of the things I really
liked in this movie is a spoiler so I
kinda had to leave you hanging just like
add movies yeah but there's some good
month in anyhow see you the spoilers I
just kind of dick but it's just the
reality of the situation really the
thing I want to talk about is Kurt
Russell egos a living planet
now this movie is completely star-lords
movie it's star-lord finding out whose
father is whether or not he's possibly
had two fathers I mean you know not
blood father's but one father I guess
like biological father and the other
like a dick I guess but I guess
you had a heart the movie starts out
Kurt Russell's all super young they're
getting better and better making people
look young with the CGI face thank man
oh man I was like not it's young Kurt
Russell right it look too young as hell
I genuinely could not tell did whatever
CGI they used on his face I'm only
actually assuming it was CGI you look so
damn good it could be old footage of
Elvis with Kurt Russell Ellen now but
he's put this little flower spore thing
on earth and he's super pumped in these
you know bangin star-lords mom he's a
planet that was an intelligence that
gathered matter around him and now he's
a planet with literal brain inside of
him but he's learned how to take human
form and now he can be Kurt Russell and
go to nail chicks another planet life of
a planet or Saturn you think about that
it looks so cool with my rings but I'm
gas so I can't do that sucks to be you
Saturn then you can make jokes about all
the planets in the solar system on
asteroid based on that premise so anyhow
star-lord is bonding with ego and at a
point nebula and Gamora come across this
really harsh truth which is like all
these bones and you're like I what's up
with this planet what are the bones so I
had heard ego the Living Planet was a
villain but for the sake of people who
might not know that I omitted that from
the spoiler free review so let's talk
about the fact that he's actually a
villain he goes a living planets a
dick who knew that only did ego
send yondu to go get Peter quill and
bring them back and was yondu did not
which actually adds a lot of character
to yondu because you thought it was a
piece of dick in the first movie
that he's like I
I like the kid he was great Oh yondu has
a heart
pretty much ego is like Al Pacino and
devil's advocate he's at all these kids
all these disappointments but this is
the one he's found his key on it but he
says the one thing is Peter Quill's all
hypnotized he's like I loved your mom
broke my heart to put that tumor in her
head and the camera just says that room
whoa Walt wall thing then he does the
erron black fatality from Mortal Kombat
X man just start shredding them and now
they're enemies he's a dick
Gilda's mom yeah planets got to go down
and this fight did something I'm gonna
take you back to Blade one for a second
here in Blade 1 Deacon Frost play by
Stephen Dorff wants to become lemagas
the blood God so he does at the end of
the movies blood God possesses him his
eyes are red he gets to a sword fight
with blade blade takes him down end of
movie spoilers for Blade 1 however you
watch the DVD I think it's in one of the
deleted scenes it's the alternate ending
in this commentary with the alternate
ending
originally when lomography possesses
Deacon Frost he becomes as big blood
hurricane she's a hurricane it was like
when we test screamed that ending for
audiences we felt the audience's pull
back and we just lost because the
audience knew Stephen Dorff face as the
enemy as the villain of the movie when
you took that away it just became a
formless nothing or like I why should I
care this movie kind of did that with me
and ego I'd opponent ego kind of revert
Sony bees the planet now and when ego
went away I was like I
where's ego he's conceptually the planet
who's trying to stop them but again I
was like reminded me of blade one kinda
lost me a bit right there which is a
bummer because this movie unlike a lot
of other Marvel movies concentrates on
the villain a lot more generally
speaking Marvel movies don't have strong
villains Loki and Obadiah Stane for the
cinematic versions those are the
villains I remember thought they did a
good job so when he kind of went away
and became a big dumb planet I was I
can't whatever that's also another scene
where one of the jokes really came at a
bad time like you know he's talking
about how he turned into a big pac-man
statue when he's doing the Superman to
fight with ego he becomes a big pac-man
Jim Adams I'm not above a pac-man joke
but the timing is a bit peculiar seeing
as how he just found out this guy put a
tuber in his mom's head and killed her
it's kind of a weird time tonally
speaking to pick up a joke like that
Andy has a brain I'm kind of nitpicking
at this point because whatever ego is in
the center of this planet in the center
of this core is going to be something
this is big floating brain there and I
would think if there is an intelligence
that gathers matter
became a something why would the brain
look just like our brain I would think
it would look different is a glowing
ball of light I think would have been
better something else an actual human
brain just seems like you're locking it
into a box sooner in terms of the
spoiler talk that's really what I like I
really liked how they did ego they made
a memorable villain tied to the hero I
liked nebula and the things we find out
about Thanos but really I'm a lot of the
execution was just kind of shouting
everything with taser face other than
the joke about taser faces name
everything was that band of pirates I
didn't care about I'm glad yondu got his
awesome space pirate funeral at the end
headed up by Sylvester Stallone I did
like the Stan Lee cameo and this one
liked a lot because there was a theory
out there that Stan Lee is one of the
watchers and that's how he's in all the
different universes and in this cameo in
this movie he's talking with the
watchers telling them about stuff they
kind of get bored and walk away but it
does show that he is somehow tied with
them I don't know if it's just a joke
but it happened in the movie so at that
point because you saw him talking to
them you have to assume and at least
humor the idea that all of Stan Lee's
cameos among the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Fox movies all the Marvel
movies are all tied together via Stan
Lee I think doesn't really need an
post-credit scene with Adam warlock if
the entire movie you look at these gold
people like why do I give a every
time there were gold people on the
screen I was like can we get back to ego
please in the end of the end credits
seems Little Miss Perfect gold lady is
sitting there and they're making Adam
warlock I was like God a snap about that
and then he filled me and I was like
that's why I got you man which does
bring to light that like the more they
expand the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it's going to be like yeah they're going
to be things I've never heard about and
possibly you've never heard about it's
okay to not know about them can't know
everything but in the end I wanted to
talk about this because a big thing that
I liked about the movie I could talk
about because it Aman spoil the whole
ego thing now you know so now that you
possibly have seen Guardian to the
Galaxy 2 have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]